so as you heard there nevada already
uses less than what will be reduced too
but there are still efforts to conserve
on the local level and new proposals
from the water district would likely
impact your neighborhood madison
kimbrough continuing our team coverage
with how some are already working to
make a difference changes to water
features are currently under
consideration by the las vegas valley
water district and if agreed upon could
go into effect that's in january so i
spoke to some residents today who are
taking conservation into their own hands
the las vegas valley water district
sending out cards in the mail looking
for feedback on new proposals some of
those changes include for one the water
district's tiered water rate structure
meaning the more you use the higher your
rate would be also the potential of
cutting golf course's water allotment by
about one-third and a restriction on new
fountains and other new ornamental water
features pat cornigay of spring valley
says water conservation efforts are a
top priority for him along with running
an affordable household and that's why
he chose to trade in his front grass
lawn for turf i was wasting water trying
to get my grass to grow in the front
yard because of all the traffic that
goes by i contacted southern
nevada water association online
did my stuff online with them and found
out that i could get a rebate if it was
approved there has been a definite
decrease i'd say 20 to 30 dollars a
month just on the front yard so i'm
pretty happy with that and i think it's
worth doing pat's neighbor maria garcia
also conscious of water use he's just
trying to
save water you know example my house
like if i don't need the faucet i
washing dishes i turn the water off or
stuff like that and to reduce
unnecessarily high water use among
single family homes an excessive use
charge is also being proposed for anyone
who uses too much in a month
and areas like henderson north las vegas
and clark county water districts working
closely with the southern nevada water
authority each district would have to
vote separately on any changes proposed
in the newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news
now